Це - Конотоп. Невелике містечко на Сумщині.
Тут трамваї ходять коліями, що їх звичайні конотопці проклали власноруч.
Центр прикрашає пам'ятник коню - один з небагатьох в Україні.
І, можливо, чаклують справжні конотопські відьми.
Ти взагалі знаєш, де перебуваєш? Це - Конотоп, тут кожна друга жінка - відьма.
Тоді росіяни так і не зайшли в місто, воно місяць було в оточенні.
А 364 роки тому російська армія зазнала тут нищівної поразки в Конотопській битві.
Нині ж у містечку триває битва "духовна" - з російськими й радянськими назвами вулиць.
Це мегаархіважливо! Це супер на часі!
Я вважаю, що це зайве.
Ми пробували боротися, ми продовжуємо боротися.
Збирали підписи, щоб не перейменовували. Але її перейменували.
У Конотопі - 427 вулиць, провулків і площ.
У 2015 році перейменували понад 70 з них.
З 2022 року змінилися ще 44 назви.
На черзі - більше сотні.
Тобто незабаром оновиться кожен другий топонім у місті.
На думку міського голови, це - вклад у майбутню перемогу над Росією.
Це супер на часі.
Бо на часі це було ще в 1991 році, це треба було зробити.
Якби ми тоді очистилися енергетично, ментально, духовно, очистили, ці всі топоніми прибрали,
ми змогли б набагато швидше і легше прибрати з свідомості багатьох
оцей комплекс меншовартості, оцей хохлізм.
Віднедавна Конотопом почали курсувати нові автобуси
- подарунок від чеського міста Острава.
А на честь директора комунального підприємства, яке передало автобуси,
- Даніеля Моріса, назвали ось цю вулицю.
Новий транспорт сюди поки не їздить.
А місцеві жителі - через понад пів року після перейменування
- ще користуються старою назвою - 6-го вересня.
За радянських часів ця назва з’явилася з нагоди звільнення міста від фашистів.
Раніше це був і день міста.
Це виходить… Вулицю купили автобусами. Якось так.
Збирали підписи, щоб не перейменовували. Але її перейменували.
Я вважаю, що нормальна назва у нас була.
Назвали б Вишнева, тут багато вишень росте.
Хай би Вишнева була, ніколи ніхто не міняв би її.
А ця вулиця - колишня Тургенєва - віднедавна носить ім'я Валерія Залужного.
Її жителі до нової назви ставляться здебільшого позитивно.
Нормально, краще, ніж Тургенєва, набагато.
Краще жити, коли все доглянуте, все добре
- на будь-якій вулиці, назва не грає жодної ролі, як на мене.
Тут стільки списів зламали, коли змінювали в 2014 році,
що тепер я все спокійно сприймаю.
Залужного так Залужного.
У Києві ж свого часу відмовилися від ідеї назвати вулицю іменем головнокомандувача ЗСУ.
Адже законом встановлено, що вулицям присвоюються імена фізичних осіб лише посмертно.
У міського голови Конотопа, батьки якого нині живуть на вулиці Залужного, є свої аргументи.
В деяких питаннях ментального характеру, стратегічного, патріотичного характеру,
я вважаю, що якщо ми десь ухвалимо рішення, яке не заборонене по суті, то нічого тут поганого немає.
Для Валерія Залужного… ми всі йому вдячні,
але ми не можемо всі вийти на проспект і кричати "дякуємо, Залужний",
але ми від всієї громади хочемо підтримати його, показати,
що ми віримо в його талант, віримо в його справедливість і силу,
ми назвали вулицю в його честь.
Це від усієї нашої 100-тисячної громади йому енергетичний посил.
Найбільше ж суперечок у Конотопі викликало перейменування вулиці Красногірської на Варшавську.
Дехто у назві "Красногірська" бачить радянський слід, дехто - ні.
Слово саме "красний" - ну що це таке?
У нас то село якесь "красне", то вулиця "красна".
Не цікаво так. Хай краще будуть нові назви.
Красногірська, "красна гора" - на що воно впливає, я не знаю.
А тепер Варшавська… Нам до Варшави ще далеко.
Я вважаю, що нічого страшного тут не було у назвах цих - Красногірська.
Якби проспект Леніна був, то добре, це так.
Так що можна було й не перейменовувати.
У нас є більш глобальні проблеми, ніж вулиці.
Співробітник місцевого краєзнавчого музею Олександр Акуліч
теж не згоден з перейменуванням.
Він вивчає історію Конотопа і проводить історичні екскурсії містом.
Красногірська - це історична назва, вона так і з'явилася під такою назвою,
її перша згадка 1725 рік, відштовхується від "красні горки",
це як "Володимир красне сонечко".
Це було одним із тригерів, після якого прискіпливо
ставляться до деяких перейменувань.
Проти перейменування виступив депутат міськради Андрій Франчук,
в окрузі якого розташована колишня Красногірська,
і активісти з громадської організації "35-ий квартал".
Їх обурило й те, що інші вулиці всупереч закону назвали іменами живих людей -
Моріса і Залужного, а також - відсутність громадських обговорень.
Ми перейменовуємо вулиці в честь людини з іншої держави,
яка ще жива, передала нам просто автобуси,
а в нас кожен день гинуть герої.
Начебто спустили все на децентралізацію,
і логіка повинна полягати в тому, що в громаді сила.
А виходить так, що на місцях якісь царьки з'являються
і можуть без думки, обговорення людей ухвалювати такі рішення.
Активісти склали петицію проти перейменувань,
зібрали достатньо підписів, утім міськрада її відхилила.
Міський голова вважає супротив перейменуванню
політичним піаром опонентів.
У самому тексті петиції написано - відмінити повністю рішення.
Тобто не в частині однієї чи двох вулиць, на яких він робить собі політичний піар,
а відмінити повністю все рішення.
А це рішення містило, зокрема, перейменування однієї з центральних вулиць міста
на вулицю імені Романа Шухевича?
Уявляєте, тобто це "животноє", яке виконує чиєсь замовлення.
Щодо думки громадськості, то нові назви для вулиць
обговорювала спеціальна комісія з дерусифікації, пояснює міський голова.
Містянам пропонували долучитися до дискусії на сторінці міськради у Фейсбуці.
Конотопці, з якими поспілкувалася DW,
не знали ані про таке обговорення, ані про факт перейменування.
Уже перейменували? Не знаю.
Я не знала, що перейменована.
-	Не чув. - І обговорення якогось не було? - Ні, не було.
В основному на роботі, тому ніколи було ті розмови й слухати.
В Інституті нацпам'яті наголошують:
процес перейменування має бути зрозумілим громаді.
В кожному випадку потрібно досліджувати,
вивчати, піднімати архіви. Тому в цій роботі
незвичайно важлива участь і дослідників,
істориків, краєзнавців для того, щоб справді цей процес був виважений,
обґрунтований і зрозумілим для всіх.
Новий закон "Про засудження російської імперської політики в Україні
та деколонізацію топонімії" набув чинності наприкінці липня цьогоріч.
За ним впродовж пів року з публічного простору мають зникнути російські й радянські топоніми.
Є винятки - для постатей, які зробили значний внесок
у розвиток певного регіону чи України загалом.
Комісія Інституту нацпам'яті розроблятиме рекомендації для органів місцевого самоврядування:
що підпадає під перейменування, а що ні, як краще обрати нову назву.
Поки така комісія у процесі створення.
Назва вулиці - це не лише як вияв пошани до творчості
того чи іншого письменника.
Насправді в радянський час це було фактично маркером вищості російської культури.
І тому усунення отаких маркерів є надзвичайно важливим сьогодні.
Це навіть відкриває шлях для того, щоб ми краще, більше дізнавалися,
пізнавали власну історію і увічнювали пам'ять про тих,
хто справді пов'язаний з тією чи іншою громадою, містом чи селом.
З конотопським краєзнавцем Олександром Акулічем ми говоримо на перехресті колишньої вулиці Леніна
- а нині Червоної Калини, і Варшавської - раніше Красногірської.
Олександр каже: війна значно підігріла цікавіть місцевих
до його історичних екскурсій і минулого рідного міста.
Так як я до 24 лютого майже не проживав у місті,
а працював у Києві і жив постійно в Києві,
то мені не додавало ентузіазму приїздити ще на вихідний.
Коли пишеш - екскурсія, а тут приходять дві людини і такий думаєш:
а навіщо я сюди їхав, кому це цікаво.
А після повномасштабного вторгнення, у людей з'явилася цікавіть - де вони живуть.
У Конотопі, за 80 кілометрів від російського кордону,
поки побоюються вішати нові таблички для перейменованих вулиць - заради конспірації.
Але не бояться класти нові дороги.
Хоча не всюди, показує нам Павло, місцевий активіст.
Це Європейська площа.
Була перейменована в рамках декомунізації в 2015 році.
Раніше називалася площею Новікова.
І за 8, навіть 9 років, тут нічого не змінилося.
Принаймні в європейську сторону так точно.
Попри все 17-річний Павло каже,
що мріє пов'язати своє життя з Конотопом.
Хлопець хоче, аби місто змінювалося не лише номінально.
Ми зверталися до влади, казали, може давайте будемо змінювати не так багато вулиць.
Але будемо змінювати на них щось фундаментальне.
Якщо ми змінили назву вулиці,
то створюємо ОСББ, проводимо якусь модернізацію,
банально робимо ремонт на дитячих майданчиках цієї вулиці.
Це не дуже дорого, але дійсно потрібно.